good evening and welcome to a live
special edition of tucker carlson
tonight i'm mark stein in fortucca who's
taking a
quiet fishing weekend but he will be
dropping by momentarily
china is the number one global power
how'd that happen to america
well sometimes you get dealt some tough
geopolitical cards as britain france
spain portugal
could surely all tell us but sometimes
you just do it to yourself
this is one of those stories that would
have been a rather dull satire a decade
ago but these days is just standard
operating procedure
from a group called dallas justice now
an open letter to wealthy white liberals
quote to our white allies talk is not
enough commit yourself towards taking
action
and making sacrifices to correct
centuries of injustice
open up spaces for black and latinx
communities by refusing to send your
kids
to ivy league and u.s news and world
report top
50 schools and encourage friends
neighbors and family members to do the
same
imagine if those hundreds of thousands
of spots at these institutions
were occupied only by marginalized
communities imagine the opportunities
we can achieve true equity within our
lifetimes
but only if white folks are willing to
sacrifice their privileges
yes indeed it's not enough for you nice
white allies
just to listen to npr and giggle at how
stupid all the white male
doofuses are in tele commercials
nowadays and admire how
that splendid u.s ladies soccer team is
so committed
to getting the taking a knee stuff just
right that it's given up goal scoring
these are mere gestures they cost you
nothing
but are you sufficiently all in to take
it to the next level
of child sacrifice at least as far as
education is concerned here's how the
pledge goes quote
as a white person with privilege both
from my whiteness and my neighborhood
i recognize the need to make sacrifices
for the purpose
of correcting hundreds of years of
murder
slavery discrimination and lack of
educational and economic opportunities
perpetrated upon people of color
i understand that access to top schools
is a key component
in economic and social advancement
therefore i commit that my
children will not apply to or attend
any ivy league school or u.s news
and world report top 50 schools so that
position at that school is available for
people of color
to help correct historical wrongs don't
be a racist hypocrite
sign the pledge today and just in case
you were thinking of tossing it on the
pile with the supermarket coupons
and the publishers clearinghouse you may
already have won postcards
dallas justice now adds this warning
quote
please note dallas justice now will be
publicly announcing
the names of those who have and have not
signed the pledge uh-huh
so if you white liberal allies are just
thinking you can point to your tax
deductible donation
to the el paso festival of aspiring
rappers that ain't gonna cut it anymore
the o'rourke family from texas tried
that to the point where their cute
little middle schooler beto
never missed an opportunity to excoriate
himself
as a white man who has had privileges
that others could not
depend on or take for granted i've
clearly had advantages over
the the course of my life the way in
which i acknowledge
the truth of the criticism that i have
enjoyed white privilege
absolutely undeniable you're right um
there are things that i have been
privileged to do in my life that others
cannot it's not because i'm a great
person or i'm a genius or i figured
anything out a lot of it has to do
with the fact that i'm a white man
okay so did you give up your place at
columbia university currently third in
the nation
and let the family pool boy go instead
no
beetho went he majored in skateboarding
with a minor in air guitar and wrote his
master's thesis
on socio-racial self-flagellation as
identity politics survival strategy
if you were a person of color you might
eventually suspect that beethoven's
constant confessions of his privilege
are simply an easy way for him to
maintain it in the 19th century white
guys made the big bucks by being
blackface minstrels
in the 20th century white guys made the
big bucks by doing
safe cover versions of black music and
now in the 21st century white guys
in this case a white guy who's whiter
than any white guy you have seen since
leave it to beaver
these white guys make the big bucks by
telling all
the other whites to be less white
professor sam
williams of the wretched penn state
university
hosts an utterly worthless class
to be less white is to be less
oppressive less arrogant
less certain less defensive less
ignorant be more humble
listen believe break with party and
break with white
solidarity what do you think about that
like i think
you know it's more or less just
recognizing
the advantages you have in life whatever
that may be
um and not thinking yourself superior
because of that
what white people would find that
offensive
um can conservatives i guess well what
what
what is like what it what's the point
it's it that it's trying to say
i don't know i don't know i want to get
cancelled so i'm trying to be careful
what i say
who have you guys oppressed in the today
i haven't impressed anyone today
are you sure of that dude you're
breathing
have you left your house today
yes okay so you may have oppressed
somebody
you may have oppressed somebody just by
breathing what a great country
america is the only place on earth where
whites can become
multi-gazillionaires by declaring that
all other whites
are bleepholes i'll never forget asking
a group
okay so what if you could just give us
feedback
on our inevitable and often unaware
racist
assumptions and behaviors and i'll never
forget this black man raising his hand
and saying it would be revolutionary
wow and you know just like just take
that in i just want all the white people
to just take that in
revolutionary that we would receive the
feedback with grace
reflect and seek to change our behavior
that's how
difficult we are wow that's how big a
a-holes we are yeah
hmm white liberals don't forget to
pre-order
robin d'angelo's forthcoming book why
you're a pathetic racist bleephole and
buying this book isn't going to change
that
so dallas justice now has correctly
if very belatedly grasped that the white
liberals
tedious pantomime of fake civilizational
disavowal and
pseudo-self-loathing isn't getting them
anywhere
and they're demanding that the o'rourke
family actually forswear colombia
university
and his fellow texas liberals do
likewise they're absolutely right this
is
win-win your kid will learn just as much
at dead buzzard junction community
college
uh well except for the uh basket weaving
and puppetry which is harder than it
looks at least
when compared to transgender and
colonialism studies
but dallas justice now is not going far
enough they should be publicly calling
on colombia and harvard and princeton to
give away their blood-soaked endowments
to historically black colleges better
yet skip that ship it straight to africa
give it to the robert mugabe school of
public integrity in bulawayo
meanwhile back in the real world
courtesy of the official government
statistics this is the most recent year
available 2019
because last year kids paid 50 grand a
year for the occasional
zoom call so who knows how the 2020
stats will shake out but just for the
record
the percentage of 18 to 24 year olds
enrolled in college by race
white's 41 blacks 37
that would be margin of error territory
if we were discussing whether mitt
romney or liz
cheney was ahead in the latest iowa
caucus poll
asians come top at 62 percent
uh but unless you're a white fifth
grader getting his butt kicked in the
county mathletes competition you can't
mention that
in second place at 47
are persons of two or more races so
these liberal progressive racial justice
types might want to call for the
reintroduction of uh
what's that what's that word that
democrat states you said
oh yes miscegenation laws and in third
place by the way at 43
of pacific islanders because we all know
that wherever you turn in american life
all the guys running everything the ceos
the university presidents the studio
heads are all samoan and palawan
social justice warriors instead of
complaining about microaggressions
should be complaining about micronesian
aggressions
i said back in the real world but in the
real real world that's to say the rest
of the planet education isn't supposed
to be about raising already
excessively high levels of self-esteem
to nuclear strength
but about boring stuff like arithmetic
literature
physics how are we doing there according
to the oecd
in math china is number one well there's
a surprise china number one
and america uh let me see here estonia
slovenia slovakia can you stroll scroll
it down a bit oh here we are
number 37 the united states just ahead
of basket case
belarus maybe all the upscale white
liberals in dallas should just agree to
send their kids to schools in belarus
same results
but a lot cheaper even with the cost of
the plane tickets to go back to those
government statistics
43 percent of pacific islanders 41
of whites 37 of blacks are in college
those numbers are all way too high
because most of those
quote unquote students are not learning
anything worth knowing so staying in
school till grade 28 grade 37
is a waste of life each year china
graduates getting close
to 10 times more stem students than
america does
because stem is difficult and doing
classics at princeton where you no
longer need to know latin and greek
or english at yale where you no longer
need to know shakespeare
isn't difficult at all chinese educators
think
math is important american educators
think math is racist it's not hard to
see where this ends
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else